Yes, it's like he went to an insane asylum. Like almost like
a comic level insane asylum and just pulled out one of the inmates
and were like, "Hey, what do you think about this video?" Yes,
that's what he's going for. You got it. This is like Brandon
Buckingham's nightmare like sleep paralysis demon. >> Yes,
yes, yes, yes, stupidly, stupidly, double the double the double
the double. Yes, yes. He's made multiple claims with no evidence
that only a would make. Once he does it 50 times in a row and
he does it in every single piece of content about every single
person, you can surmise what his goal is.
>> I think we're on to the Brandon Buckingham video finally.
If you guys are unfamiliar,
Purple Perry Gaming
did a
a whole stream on Brandon Buckingham with Brandon Buckingham
was in the hospital. All right, Brandon Buckingham was in the
hospital with with I think multi-system organ failure and Purple
Perry came out basically said, "I don't think I I think this
guy's faking it." in a way that was totally trolling, completely
trolling, obviously trolling, and I I'm not even saying that.
I think I had a discussion with people, maybe Queeman at the
time. I might have even said this to Perry, where I was like,
"Oh, this this like kind of take I've I've said this to Perry
before. This is like the kind of take where you're basically
solidifying what kind of content creator you're going to be,
right? Like once you're solidified in the broad consciousness
as the kind of as the guy who like said Brandon Buckingham was
faking his illness,
you're you're now like a satirical
goofy ass content creator. You don't really get to have serious
opinions that people will take seriously anymore. You sort of
just get You get to be the goofy like Sam Hyde type of guy who's
going to say insane things cuz you're a comedian. Which I think
that fits Perry way better, to be honest.
And I said I I think it'd be tough to grow through like networking
this way, but if if he ever gets like a response from these people,
it could really blow up. And then the Wendigo tweet happened.
I think there was Wendigo replied to Perry or some tweet about
Perry and he was calling it it out as fake, right? And
and that blew it up and a bunch of people saw it, right? A bunch
of people saw that. And I was like, "Okay, I think it I think
that's it." And this really has cemented it, where he is just
this guy now, okay? Totally cemented. Because Brandon
a YouTuber with 1.26 million subs, released a video that's already
got 230,000 views, okay?
It's already got 9 hours ago 213,000
All right? And it's just on Perry. It's It's It's only on Perry.
It is literally the most pathetic man on the internet.
It's just about Perry. Bro, they got really high-res images of
Perry for the thumbnail, too. Damn.
It's just It's just a total like Perry takedown video. But unfortunately,
Brandon Buckingham, from what I can tell, seems to have misread
the
He seems to have misread the tone of Perry's content like entirely.
And he takes all of it seriously. He seems to have taken every
single thing in this seriously.
Which is baffling.
Because this is the guy who is the million-dollar extreme super
fan who made the big million-dollar extreme documentary
and hung out with Sam Hyde and crew for like years.
How does he not know
what like How does he not know what this like meta-ironic satire
is? How does he not get it at all?
And nothing underscores how absurd I thought Brandon Buckingham's
response is
than this clip right here, okay? Has this guy made any rap music?
Is he angry because he's tried to rap and he just like sucks
at it? Let's figure that out here. My organs don't work. My organs
don't work. My organs don't work. My organs don't work. I went
to Milly's to resolve the tick addies. I talked to Sam. He agreed
to [__] All right, this guy So this guy is
He played that seriously. He played the clip of Perry trying
to freestyle over a super fast song
where it's just like larping as Brandon Buckingham saying my
organs don't work over and over again. He played that totally
seriously and was like, "Yeah, this this guy is dumb."
I You could hear
from like miles away you could hear how hard my hand slapped
into my face, okay? To facepalm on this one. Like my
goodness. It's crazy. All right? So, anyway, that's the starting
point. While I was in the hospital on the brink of death, a tornado
of was brewing. The internet's attention economy has spawned
humanoid cockroaches that will say anything for a few moments
of online notoriety. Well, let me introduce you to the most pathetic
man on the internet. His name is Purple Perry Gaming. On the
same day that I informed my audience that my heart, liver, and
kidneys were all failing, this desperate loser took to Twitter
to say this. Insane YouTuber and rapper @BuckinghamShow exposed
for faking his hospital GoFundMe scare, recording in a possibly
fake hospital set, not showing medical documents regarding his
condition. And attached is a video of him toy jacking about my
IV pump that is battery powered. Holy [__] it's not
even plugged in.
It's not even plugged in. And this tweet is by far his most successful,
gaining over 4 million views, showing just how stupid the algorithm
really is. He followed that up by posting a photo of my wife
and daughter saying, "Brandon, we will be running a train on
your wife once you kick the bucket to keep her company. Choo
choo." As well
you guys Do you guys recognize that
Does anyone else recognize that comment?
Okay, one I will point out that by doing these black bars, you
might miss the fact
Perry himself censored the picture of the kid. Perry didn't post
the picture of his kid, okay? But also,
this is the precise line that Brandon Buckingham said to Sneako,
that Sneako freaked out about and said was like totally over
the line, totally crazy, and Brandon Buckingham was starting
to rape his wife. Then I hear a bunch of people, I've actually
seen this at a couple places, people saying, "So, this guy just
threatened to rape your wife?" It's like, "Dude, how can you
be such a self-unaware
so un-self-aware sheep? How can you be so un-self-aware?" It's
crazy. The guy you follow literally did this. It's like Perry
Like Perry totally owned this guy.
And I don't even know if he had a like a conception in his head.
He had no concept of a plan even, okay? He There was He didn't
conceive of anything like this happening. It's crazy.
be running a train on your wife once you kick the bucket to keep
her company. Choo choo." Mind you, I have never interacted with
this Maltese Manlet a single time in my entire life.
I said something Oh, this is very funny. Maltese Manlet.
I said this before and I can't reiterate this enough.
If you are
If somebody's making a criticism of you, it means nothing. They're
way smaller than you. They have nothing You have nothing to gain
from like taking them down. I just don't understand why you do
this. Perry is like below you. You can make You can make an argument
that somebody is like a total cockroach and below you in every
possible way, but then if you give them your attention, you are
going down to their level. Right? Like you are a loser if you're
going to give your attention to a total cockroach in every possible
way that isn't doing any harm to you. The only harm here is that
Perry might have made this guy annoyed.
That's it.
As long as you ignore it, Perry gains nothing from this. There's
no There's no way he could win out of this. The only way you
help Perry at all is by talking about it. Yeah, but he's done
that already, BB Poison. He's done the offhanded comment and
you can take an offhanded shot just to make that guy just to
be like, "Fuck you, I know about you, but I'm not even going
to reference you." You can do that, and he did it. And then he
made a whole video on his main channel. Already almost 250,000
views, not even 10 hours. >> saying all this solely because
he is desperate for my attention. So, today we're going to be
addressing this lying freak who has been groveling at my feet
for 12 weeks straight like an attention starved pig. But first,
let me tell you about this awesome company that has been helping
me recover from being the sickest I've ever been in my entire
That's an insane transition.
to check them out. Now, back to Purple Gaming. This guy has made
seven videos and live streams on his channel with my name in
the title. With his In 12 weeks, only seven? Out of the 4 million
view tweet?
That's actually liar, fraud, incubated. Dude, what the hell's
going on, man?
Only seven Only seven live streams and videos. That's actually
crazy. >> most popular video by far being this one titled
Why You Shouldn't Donate to Brandon Buckingham. And the thumbnail
is a picture of me with the words Like every frame of this video
is Brandon Buckingham owning himself.
Yeah, this guy's most popular video is 26,000 views total and
it's on me. All of his other channels are on
Okay? You're You're literally dunking on yourself with this clip
in your video.
I said that intentionally.
His most popular video on his channel is about me. 26,000 views.
You've amplified him 10x in 9 hours. Why You Shouldn't Donate
to Brandon Buckingham. And the thumbnail is a picture of me with
the words liar, fraud, and incubated on it. A lot of my friends
over on Patreon messaged me this video and told me that they
wanted to see me react to it. Apparently, it came out while I
was in the hospital, so I That's definitely Perry fans who signed
up for his Patreon just to say, "Hey, you should watch this video.
Hey, you should watch this video. Hey, you should watch this
video." >> go outside, get some sun, and see what this
dumbass has to say about me. Let's get into it. What the [__]
is this? Is this like the director? Is this the like owner of
the hospital set that you're using? He's like watching to make
sure that you guys aren't doing this set of a fake hospital.
Never asked for help before, but my heart is currently only working
at 15 to 20%. Oh yeah, is that what the unplugged medical equipment
is saying? 15 to 20%? So yeah, the first 52 He's not intubated,
so it couldn't be intubated, okay? But Jesus. Like
Like can we just be real? Like there's already you can totally
dismiss what he's saying. He's just making things up. He's just
making things up. He just made it up. He just made it up. He
just made it up. Oh yeah, is that what the unplugged medical
equipment is saying? 15 to 20%? So yeah, the first 52 seconds
of his video is a coming up teaser, which is just a compilation
of all the stupidest things he says in the video, I'm assuming.
Um he's saying that my IV pump isn't plugged in. Uh yeah, he
I guess he's saying it's a fake
I think he showed a image of my dad and asked if it was the hospital
director.
Which is just I mean, so far that was just really stupid. I
I don't know. Medical City Health Care. What kind of [__]
name is Medical City Health Care? That's like saying this is
the This is the doctor hospital. This is the health hospital.
What the [__] Is this even a real hospital, man?
Is this Dude. This is This actually somehow, despite cutting
90% of the content, this perfectly captures what a Perry stream
is like. He just looks at at stuff, and then he pauses, and he
waits, and he just tries to riff on whatever's in frame. Like
he just tries to make a joke about whatever the [__]
in frame at any given moment in time. And if there's nothing
there, then he has to riff harder, okay? Like that's This is
literally what the Perry stream is. This is way more obvious
than I thought it was going to be. It's so obvious. That's like
part of the bit is how obviously he's just like not really caring
about what's going on. He's just trying to make funny things
up about what's happening in any kind of situation, okay? Is
this like some [__] set in some [__]
TV show? All right, dude. This might be hard to get through.
Why would it be a set? Why would I be on a set? But yeah, Medical
City Health Care is a part of the Medical City Dallas
health care system. So you could just kind of Google it. I didn't
invent the hospital. And yeah, they I guess they have branded
cups.
Hey, Purple Perry Gaming. You just got
fact-checked, bro. You just got I Deep boomed better for that.
Fact-checked, dude. You've been fact-checked by Brandon Buckingham
and his team of scientists.
Turns out, this is a This is a real hospital. You can Google
it.
Absolutely debunked. >> it matter? Like it's insane. Why
does it matter that you have a kids? Pull yourself up by your
bootstraps. Do your [__] job. Get your wife to open
an OnlyFans, you stupid piece of [__] You stupid
[__] Put some [__] work in. Don't make
me [__] put your bill for your [__] degenerate
[__] drug addicts Los Angeles networking lifestyle.
Oh, he's saying my wife should start an OnlyFans. What's this
guy's deal? What's wrong with this guy?
He's a comedian, by the way. He's like a He's like a comedian
who's always hung out with comedians.
Oh, this guy's like seriously arguing my wife should start an
OnlyFans. What's wrong with this guy?
Dude, what? >> This is a Hopefully everyone from Malta
isn't like this. People from Malta should disavow this guy, cuz
this is a bad representation of your country. My beautiful wife.
My beautiful stay-at-home wife. Oh, she's a stay-at-home wife,
so she's not busy. Open up an OnlyFans. Get her to open up an
OnlyFans. In some countries you get killed for saying something
like that. [laughter] I think that What?
What? Brandon Buckingham threatens to kill Purple Perry Gaming,
question
What? Did Did Brandon Buckingham just say Purple Perry Gaming
should be killed immediately? Is that what he said? Jesus Christ,
man. When someone is this stupid and hateful and just miserable,
all you can do is like uh hit them with the I'll pray for you.
Get a job. Get a job, you Or make a massive video marketing their
satire to the entire world for Like Trust me, there'll be some
fans of this channel, Brandon Buckingham. It's why he's up so
badly. There is almost certainly some Sam Hyde Sam Hyde fans
on here. There will be people who like like edgy, ironic meta
commentary like that. Like like ironic commentary like that,
right? Like you literally just advertised somebody who's clearly
funnier than you. Apparently, you don't get any of the humor
in the weirdest way possible by not understanding any of the
humor. You're basically your own mark. You You have become the
mark that you once preyed on. Or at least some of your fans would
have laughed at getting preyed on. You are the mark.
How? How? [__] you That beats. Get a job, you lazy
loser. How do I provide for? 4 days ago I woke up >> I
provide for her. She's disabled. She can't No, you get Get her
to open an It's not It's not like satire. It's not even hard
to understand. It's like he's saying things that are intentionally
wrong and inflammatory with no intention of backing them up.
He doesn't think they're real, right?
And he laughs along like a He laughs like a dumb at the things
he says. He says things that are insane enough that he he breaks
his character and starts laughing at himself midstream all the
He'll go to say something stupid, and he literally breaks character
laughing at himself and how stupid the thing he just said was.
And it's a consistent pattern through all of his streams. >> OnlyFans,
and then maybe you'll earn your [__] keep in this
[__] world. What's this guy's problem, dude? So this
Purple Perry guy keeps talking about my wife doing OnlyFans,
and it made me get on my phone really quick. Pretty quickly,
the only thing that I can even find about him that isn't just
the videos he's posting is an interview he does where this guy
is asking him why he follows and looks at
>> This one's epic. There's one called Iron Lily. That
one you could even argue was
But no one No one called me out on it. In chat, Bobby B asked,
"Did you expect people to question you following um
Dude. Oh man.
This guy went through the dregs. Dude, I feel I feel so bad.
This is clipped so disingenuously. Uh cry me a river over that
one, Gwala. Like he could get clipped disingenuously,
I'm pretty sure. It's not a It's not like a big deal.
Every single person who's like referencing this This is uh It's
just very funny, okay? This is very interesting. These are like
chatters who will stream to like three viewers. Not I'm not even
talking [__] Everybody starts somewhere, but like
the level of stream you have to go down to to find this stuff
is crazy.
It's wild. No. I mean, I guess it doesn't matter here, but I
didn't. But you see what I mean, right? That's okay. Like to
the point that apparently they're just pulling up comics on stream.
Not really concerned about it. This is my far the worst. Yeah.
This is. This is pretty bad. I stand by it. It's my point, you
know? And what's even more ironic in regards to Purple Perry
Gaming being into content is he had this to say about people
who watch my videos. Brandon's
>> The pot calls the kettle black, eh? This is a deeply
disturbed young boy. Imagine Imagine being so irritating
with your stupid satire, you stupid commentary you do. You're
so irritating that somebody edits together your own highlight
reel highlight reel owning them and puts it out to their audience.
Like a massive YouTuber. You're literally so [__]
to like everyone that you've irritated this guy into editing
together a highlight reel of you dunking on him to put out to
his audience.
And like if one of these points
was like kind of over exaggerated and the rest were serious,
I would maybe get it. But they're all totally fantastical, totally
unbelievable. It's like almost like there's a pattern of him
making statements that are not possible, that are like not real
at all.
It's almost like
he's just making [__] up, and it's not serious, and
nobody takes him seriously. So you You taking it seriously is
granting him some amount of seriousness
for no reason. Some amount of like clout for no reason. Boy,
I hear. But uh yeah, good for him. He's standing by his
uh enjoyment.
There is There is Hold on. There is like an outside chance that
Brandon watched some of this stuff and laughed legitimately and
thought it would be funny to do a video like taking totally biting
the bait and taking it seriously. There's like a tiny tiny point
0001% chance
that I actually kind of almost I think know that isn't possible,
but there's like some tiny chance that he could have been like,
"Oh, this guy's actually kind of funny. I'm going to respond
to this very seriously."
My wife completely deaf. My feet were
It's not even plugged in. Dude, look at Dude, Dude, holy It's
It's not even plugged in. It's not even plugged in. It's not
even plugged in. It's not even [__] plugged in. It's
not even [__] plugged in. He counts all the repeats.
>> It's not even It's not even [__] plugged
in.
It's like The wires are going to it. The [__] blue
wires are going to it, and it's not even [__] plugged
in. It's a
Dude.
I think that stupid People will say something over and over to
try to make you more convinced of what they're
The IV pump has batteries,
so it doesn't need to be plugged in. Um Actually, the IV pump
has batteries.
Actually, you're Debunked again.
You've been debunked again, Brandon Buckingham.
You are debunked, Brandon. You are totally debunked now.
Dude, it's I'm sorry.
By the way, I I told Perry I like I don't take him seriously.
I don't usually talk to him on stream. Like I would never have
him on stream for anything serious because this is his character.
I've explained this to him in private before. I don't think you're
serious. I don't think I don't take you seriously. So if I'm
talking about something serious, I'm literally not going to talk
to you if I'm talking about something serious. I would not take
you serious or I would not have you on stream. And this stuff
is like
you're taking it totally seriously. You become the fool when
you take them
No, they don't drama 101. They don't. They don't. You're You're
as as Brandon Buckingham. No, the none of the comments here are
meant to be taken seriously.
At at best you do an offhanded comment at some point in the future.
But here's the here's the thing about this, right? When when
somebody's doing this kind of satire, the only the only thing
you can do is not engage. That's all you can do.
Because they're not speaking seriously. They don't have credibility.
You taking it seriously, you're getting upset about it. You just
ignore it. The only wins they get are when somebody takes it
seriously and gets upset about it.
That's the only thing.
It's You know, I don't know if I can continue reacting to
this sort of applies. So if if Perry were like harassing this
guy, let's say Perry were the smaller creator or something or
sorry, the bigger creator. I It's like if you were getting harassed
by somebody doing this, that would be more difficult. Or I think
when the when the messages happened that Loader Box complains
about that are like totally made up, like they're totally they're
totally farcical.
When those things happen, it's like you can ban those chatters.
But like engaging seriously with those chatters, not going to
be fruitful, right? If they're saying that you like love watching
kids get You just ban them. Right? If they want to make a real
point, they can make a real point. But they're not making a real
point. They're just goofy.
Anyway. Yeah,
there's no beeping. There's no beeping. But he's connected to
it with all these wires. What Where is Like we have this little
thing here. Where does it go?
Universal across every even adjacent communities think it's hilarious
that Brandon responded and not in a good way for Brandon. Every
single Perry fan is delighted today. Like totally delighted.
Like there literally couldn't have been a better thing that would
happen this year for anybody who's a Perry fan is Brandon Buckingham
responding to this video in any way. Where it goes like there?
Where does it go? Dude, is this actually a scam? Yeah, what am
I supposed to say to
This is like colossal levels of Like what what's this over here?
What's this down here? What are these boxes? Are these like Are
these like earbud box? What is this? Dude, like he's looking
at the Rode Wireless Go boxes and he's like, "What's this? What
is that? Oh." He's like desperately looking for stuff to try
to prove that I'm not sick in the hospital dying. Is this even
an The only W for Brandon is his audience upon after Perry. I'm
assuming you mean like brigading or harassing Perry. Perry loves
that. Perry loves everything up to and including Brandon Buckingham
showing up in Valletta and The only The only thing that I think
Perry would be a little upset about, but he'd probably with his
artist soul truly be behind this actually is just showing up
to showing up in Valletta. That would probably be like that might
be neutral for him. But he is an artist and he would think that
that's like probably the best outcome for his art, okay?
Like that that might actually
you know, in heaven he would be laughing. In hell, he would be
laughing.
He'd be crying, okay? >> man? Is it I know that. It doesn't
even have any hospital noises. You know, I've been to a hospital
before. Now, mind you, I mean it's like the main hospital in
Malta. Maybe there's like some side hospital. There's no beeping.
I can't imagine seeing somebody sick in the hospital and reacting
this way. This What What are we Who the [__] is this?
Who the [__] is this? Is this like the director?
Who the [__] is this? Do you see this? Who the [__]
is this? Is this like the Is this the like Is this the [__]
owner of the hospital set that you're using? Is this the owner
of the hospital set that you're using? Is this like the owner?
Dude, dude what the [__] is this, man? That's my
dad.
Refund No, no, no. Can I Can I get one? Can I Uh [screaming]
maybe there's some art in like the dry delivery to these things,
tell you. I am laughing a lot at this video. I do actually like
this video. It is bringing me great joy to watch this video.
Maybe there's some art in the response. I don't know. I put
I don't know. I got to request a refund.
That's That's my dad. >> That's Chrome, pay attention.
Um thanks for your kindness. We're protecting your donation.
If you're a donor and would like to refund, believe there's been
an authorized charge, our team can help. Okay, so Chrome, click
contact us and I guess they'll help you from there. They'll help
you from there. So contact us and then when you're talking to
the AI bots, say that you have good reason to believe Brandon
Buckingham is scamming and then link them my video and then link
them my video and then link them my video. What's this?
Guys, guys, amazing news. Amazing news. Amazing news. Amazing
news, guys. We did it. We did it, guys.
We We did it. We We did it. All right, so one of the people I
guess in his chat had donated to me. It's Chronic Sonic. It is
Chronic
>> Hi, I recently made a 15 euro donation 15 pound donation
to Brandon Buckingham and I'd like a refund.
All right, so one of the people I guess in his chat had donated
to me. He got them to refund their donation.
And he's like super proud of that. You might be wondering what
kind of person
I am almost positive. Actually, in fact, I'm totally positive
that that that donation was only made to be clawed back intentionally.
I don't believe for a second that Chronic Sonic saw Brandon Buckingham's
post and was like, "I'm going to give a bunch of money cuz I
I feel really bad for this guy." I'm almost positive that didn't
happen. The donation was only made so that he could request a
refund and do that bit. >> and donates to a GoFundMe and
then revokes their donation. Well, his name is Chronic Sonic
and let's hear what he had to say. Well, someone said, "You're
going to make the make it through this." And I replied, "He won't."
And then And then the guy replied to me, "Pray to a curse fish
now." And I
Chronic Sonic loves Indians, okay? He's Indian himself. He wants
Indians to be respected on the internet.
Oh, Chronic Sonic did feel bad for him. Perry debated him into
refunding.
Jesus Christ. Okay. Um past two years, Gentle Whale. I might
have something, but I'll have to think about it. Give me a a
time where I'm not reacting to The Jimmy guy I have to correct
the record. The Jimmy guy, the guy from the previous clip, he's
got 14 viewers right now, okay? 14 viewers. I said three. That
was a lie.
I got I was off. Well, someone said, "You're going to make the
make it through this." And I replied, "He won't." And then And
then the guy replied to me, "Pray to a curse fish now." And I
replied to him, "I'm a Christian. I know Brandon's going to hell."
That's basically what I said. What's wrong with this guy? It
would have been pretty gnarly if I died and this was like what
he was saying. But I guess, you know, I found Let me I'll put
a video right now.
I'm sorry to say,
they would have only found that funnier.
They would have found that way funnier.
Surely he has to realize that. >> on Twitter that someone
posted towards Turkey Tom and this guy's like mocking
You'll see. If I survive, it'll be a long way to recovery.
You hear that, Tom? Looks like your friend's going to be a [__]
turnip for the He's roasting Queenin, too? That's [__]
up, man. >> rest of his life. How unfortunate, huh? Heart
failure.
>> Oh, he's going to die. That's a joke. Queenin comes
up later, though. I'm not joking. Nope. Don't I missed I missed
it. I misfired. I know Queenin comes I knew Queenin comes up
in the video. I misread the situation. My >> you're sticking
up for your little friend who got hurt.
But I think
it overall is pointless. I think anyone who donates is an idiot.
Tell them I said reach for the stars.
See you. All the people that
Like why why would you ever think that you should tangibly respond
to somebody like that or give them attention?
I don't un
I We all understand that would be the bad that would be a bad
thing to do,
To to give these people attention. That guy, too?
give someone who's in the hospital really hard time. They don't
even know the person. There's no reason behind it,
I think they're very like sick, dysgenic, evil people that are
like
and like have some mental or physical
deformity that makes them hideous. Dude.
>> What? SUCH A DUMB TRANSITION, BRO. WHAT
THAT'S SUCH A
THIS guy did in a 4-second
in a 4-second comment what Stardust attempted to do with her
entire stream last night and whatever time she put into her PowerPoint
presentation. That did a thousand times more damage than anything
Stardust has ever done. It's so bad, man. They're like sick,
dysgenic, evil Hold on. Hold on. give someone who's in the hospital
really They don't even know the person. There's no reason behind
it, really. I think they're very like sick, dysgenic, evil people
that are like miserable
and like have some mental or
deformity that makes them hideous. And he's in the hospital now,
cuz he was
Oh my god.
As that was crazy, okay? That was crazy. Cuz you think it's going
to go back to Perry, but it actually cuts to Queenman. [__]
off. >> up in the in the fatty too hard.
He was hitting the sizzle up in the fatty too hard. He's in hospital.
And if you know the Queenman lore, okay?
Queenman got the worst haircut of his life, okay?
The worst haircut of his life. He's still cammed up. And the
one time he cammed up with the worst with the worst haircut of
his life is the is the stream where he commented on Brandon Buckingham.
Giving Brandon Buckingham this so amazing reputation with all
these reputable people. Uh no. All the people who like Brandon
are stupid scum.
I think like
Still kind of hits though, a little bit. Still kind of still
kind of hits a little bit, cuz they are stupid scum. >> A
well-to-do
nice person
would not say these things. And if you are saying these things
You no sh Yeah, no sh
Thank you. Wow. This guy's This guy's basically Socrates. I think
it's really mean that you guys were mean to be when I was in
the hospital. No sh Thank you. Thank you. >> have the like
physiognomy of the Could you imagine making this video and then
your friends are Sam Hyde and Turkey Tom?
Your two best friends, your two most known friends of the past
like 5 to 10 years are Sam Hyde and Turkey Tom. I just think
it's crazy how people are mean on the internet. Two best friends,
Sam Hyde and Turkey Tom. Zero introspection. Actually zero introspection.
I've never seen Sam Hyde be so be randomly mean to somebody.
I've never seen Turkey Tom take like a total lolcow whose life
is destroyed and laugh at them, make fun of them for hours. I've
never seen any of those things, guys. Wow.
Would not say these things. And if you are saying these things,
you probably have the like physiognomy of this guy or this other
guy. Which is, you know
You can be ugly and [__] up and still be a nice guy.
You don't have to be like this. Is there a baby Almost definitely.
You could be attractive and still be [__] up and
and love doing this kind of thing.
Actually, no logic in that. But we don't know for 100%. Um anyway,
I'm telling you guys I've censored this photo. I censored it.
That baby looks hella nice. That baby needs a helmet. Let's just
say that. No, obviously they can't help it. It's Brandon Buckingham's
fault, really. I'm not listen. Brandon
hella re
It's pretty brave of this guy to call my 1-year-old daughter
re looking when he looks like this. Is he like he's like watching
to make sure that you guys aren't ruining the cassette of a fake
hospital? The good news is you know everything I Yeah, he's not
even pale either. He's like he's like all [__] red
in the face. He's like red in the face. Dude, he looks like he's
just got [__] down from [__] a whole
weekend of party. And he's pretending to be dying.
This guy I'm Hella [__] Watch it back. It's pretty
brave of this guy to call my 1-year-old daughter re looking when
he looks like this. Is he like he's like watching to make sure
that you guys aren't ruining the cassette of a fake hospital?
The good news is everything I Yeah, he's not even pale either.
He's like he's like all [__] red in the face. He's
like red in the face.
A whole weekend of party. And he's pretending to be dying.
>> That is the allegation. Little awkward.
Little awkward.
Is he
I Okay, I will be real though. At least he didn't go, "Well,
actually my kid's not re if you want to know. They're like perfectly
normal." At least he didn't respond with that, okay?
A few months ago I was in the ICU.
You know, I don't know if he's just completely stupid or if he's
just like disingenuous and does everything in bad faith because
Yep. Well, kind of both, but not really the first one as much.
Not really the first one. Two ad reads? Well, he's got to pay
up he's got to make up for those hospital bills, okay? The GoFundMe
only did so much.
All right? Got to He's making his money back.
completely stupid or if he's just like disingenuous and does
everything in bad faith because Yes, that's the that's the one.
Which is obvious. Which is obvious
to anybody watching.
Should be obvious to you if you have any number of brain cells.
He's made multiple claims with no evidence that only a re would
make. Once he does it 50 times in a row and he does it in every
single piece of content about every single person, you can surmise
what his goal is. Because there was this image going around of
me with a pink-haired girl where I'm flexing money, smoking a
cigar, and have a hospital band on. And the caption is, "He's
all right and so is your money." And this is a completely AI'd
photo. I don't know who this person is. They're just >> making
this image to get clicks online and I guess uh you know, troll
me a bit. And Purple Perry quote tweets it and says, "Holy hell,
he's actually bragging about scamming his audience." But I'd
like to think he's actually smart enough to know it's AI and
he's just like a pathetic [__] that is trying to
get attention by any means possible. Anyway
Well, my whole thing where I was like, "He doesn't know what
he's doing cuz otherwise he wouldn't be giving him the attention."
I don't even know what to say. I don't even know what to say
now.
I actually I don't know what to say. See it, Hiroko?
Okay, so he considered this. I would love to hear Now, if that
is how what he is, here's why I'm responding anyway. Anyway,
let's get back to the reaction. I'll say one thing about this
video, it's effective at defeating your desire to want to watch
it. I will also likely need to be on heart medication the rest
of my life. Well, wow wow wow wow wow wow. I'm a millionaire.
I have to pay $10 a month for heart medication. I'm not a millionaire.
Do my my RPM is like No way. No shot.
This is like This is like showing Spin Boy her mortgage.
You You think I'm You think I'm poor? Here's all my money. You
think I have a mortgage? It's like the same thing. You just got
baited by somebody who's only trolling you, only trying to [__]
with you into showing your revenue.
His sponsors are too. It is pretty disingenuous cuz he's getting
sponsors from some advertising company, from some sponsorship,
right? He's getting sponsors from something.
on heart medication the rest of my life. Well, wow wow wow wow
wow wow. I'm a millionaire. I have to pay $10 a month for heart
medication. I'm not a
Do my my RPM is like $4.50.
I'm not a millionaire. I'm I'm not even a hundred-thousandaire.
I have expenses. I have a family.
It's very expensive to fly two camera guys out to film things,
right? Pay for lodging and airfare. If I was a millionaire, I
wouldn't be making a GoFundMe. And that's why my Patreon members
are so important. Speak
Dude, shut up. Holy shilling. guarantee. And I just posted the
first episode of my new podcast where I'm talking about what
it was like for me to be sick, how it affected my family, and
Did I just know nothing about Brandon Buckingham? Was he like
a total hippie type that like was all peace and love from the
very beginning? Cuz I could have sworn from like the Sneako stuff
where he's like, "We're going to We're going to Me and the boys
going to run a train on your girl, bro. Choo choo." I could have
sworn that he was like some edgy kind of dude. And now
at the end of the day he's coming out here being like "Man, it's
not worth it being mean online, guys.
Being mean online sucks."
and how my recovery's going so far. So, check that out right
now on Patreon. Yeah, I obviously things can change, but it's
not in. It's not in, guys. It's it's not even in. It's not even
in. It's not even in. What the There he is. He's back saying
it's not even plugged in. Great video. Sick video. This is
I truly If you want to be, you know, if you want the true black
pill
If this launches, I feel like this could launch Perry up like
above viewership.
Uh like in viewership above like everybody he's around. Like
I think this has the potential to launch Perry into like like
basically like the Nicholas De Orio level of viewership somehow.
I'm not joking. I actually think it could do that. Like this
video has the capacity to do that. I'm not joking.
This is like the exact opposite, the polar opposite of what you
want to do. >> It's a fun watch, guys. My heart is currently
only working at 15 to 20%. Oh yeah, is that what the Is that
what the unplugged Is that what the unplugged medical equipment
is saying? 15 to 20%? Is that what the unplugged medical equipment
that isn't beeping is saying? The medical equipment doesn't tell
you what your ejection fraction is. That's an echocardiogram.
You have to go to like uh imaging place to get it. >> Is
this like a What is Is like a tampon?
Debunked again. Purple Perry Gaming. The Maltese
Wait, what did he say? The Maltese manlet Purple Perry Gaming.
Bro, we insult we We don't even hate Perry. We insult him better
than you do, bro. What are you doing? >> Why is he like
on his head? The Maltese meatball to you. And here? Like on his
head. This looks like what is like a tampon that he just put
on his head. Like what is this? What is this bracelet What is
this He's still red in the face. He's like It just doesn't No.
No. The bracelet is a hospital bracelet. The tampon on my arm
is where they drew blood because my IVs were getting
clogged essentially cuz I had been in the hospital for days
by the time I filmed this video. I don't know what that's called.
I'm not a doctor, but that's a thing that happens.
Debunked again. You've been You've been debunked again, Perry.
It's over. >> Cough cough I'm dying. But don't show people
I'm balding. Make sure I try Can I wear a beanie? Can I wear
I need to I don't want people to see that I'm Please do not Please
do not take your hat off and show that you're not balding. Please,
for the love of God, do not take your hat off and try to show
that you're not balding, actually.
>> to wear He used to wear one of those bandannas to hide
the fact that he's balding. This guy is so in such an insecure
loser. Anyway, anyway. I used to wear a bandanna to hide that
I'm balding? When when was that? I don't
What's wrong with this guy? Now, this is where This is where
I get into my second post, okay? I made the first post about
the clip and
but I eventually I'd watch enough of this video and I had to
go and make the second post, okay? Under that same that same
post, okay? It's staggering how this guy went from MDE super
fan to taking the bait from such an obvious troll. Anyone who
told Brandon that making this video was a good decision is an
awful friend. Literally any friend who didn't go to this guy
and say, "This is totally
You're a complete for doing this. Anybody who didn't borderline
like try to sabotage his devices to prevent the upload of this
video is an awful friend. Yes, it's rage bait the entire time,
Orange Kush. Yes. Yes, it's it's entirely rage bait because it
has to be rage bait.
It's more rage bait than like Pearl. Just Pearly Things. It's
worse than that. It's way worse than that.
He went to his friends at Million That's actually believable.
If he went to his friends at Million Dollar Extreme and was like,
"Should I respond to this?" And they're like, "Yeah, absolutely.
That's really Those are really bad allegations, man." I could
see it.
We're back to the video. There's no way he did that. The dude.
I have not seen that part. I predicted that. I'd not seen that
part.
Holy crap, dude. Um
This is low. My food's here. One second. >> was bad. You
would hear the the many liters of oxygen going into his nose.
What you're telling me Wait, Boor. You're telling me that when
people's hearts is working at 15% drug 50% capacity,
they might not tell breathing? And you're tell You're telling
me, Boor, that they wouldn't switch off the the machine next
to him? They wouldn't switch it off? They wouldn't switch it
off? They wouldn't just like let the cord dangle? And that's
why we would hear like a machine which is helping him live as
opposed to like that silence? >> in the ICU. I don't listen
to what this like scamming loser is saying. >> This guy's
calling me a scamming loser.
This is This is like This is the worst This is the worst video
I've ever made. They're reacting to this. This is like the worst
video I've ever made. This is like if you were to go to an insane
Bro, there's no way Wait. There's no way he just did like a reaction
to it out in the woods or some [__]
I will say he's describing Perry's like
hm tableau the tableau Perry is attempting to paint perfectly.
Yes, it's like he went to an insane asylum. Like almost like
a comic level insane asylum and just pulled out one of the inmates
and were like, "Hey, what do you think about this video?" Yes,
that's what he's going for. You got it.
I've ever made. This is like if you were to go to an insane asylum
and then try to debate an insane person, you would wind up sounding
crazy.
Can you get a shot of that bird over there?
Dude, there's no way Wait. Just hold on. Oh God, this is the
problem with with meta irony, right?
Yeah. You would. You would, actually, if you if you did this.
If you went and you debated an insane person like this, you would
look insane.
Also, if you debated somebody who's trying to look insane, you
would look
He's He was so close to saving himself >> good part of
the video. Can you get a good zoom on that? This is how you know
like I'm This is where I stopped thinking it's a joke.
Guys, it's the one good part of the video. Look, there's a bird
over there.
The thing is an Isn't life amazing? I just love living life,
guys. I almost died. So, I love living life and experiencing
life and being out in nature and living life and experiencing
life. Animals, rivers, rocks,
outside.
Great. See, now we're getting good content.
Now we're getting some good stuff. >> I don't know to be
fair I don't know I don't know what they do in these situations
where they don't know what's going on. I feel like they would
they would be louder. I just know it would be louder, dude. He's
putting on a strong face. So brave. So brave. Um Could be a private
hospital since he's so rich. A private hospital where where they
where they just leave the cord dangling? I don't [laughter] know,
man. Maybe. [clears throat] I don't know what to say, guys. He
stumped me with his stupidity. Is there like fake hospital hospital
TV set, Texas? Is there Can we find like Is there like uh Is
anyone I don't know. I'm not in the industry. Hospital sets for
filming. Does anyone know where he was from, guys? Does anyone
know where he was from? Does anyone know? Does anyone know? I
don't know. Maybe we could find the set. That would be That would
say a lot, wouldn't it? That would say a lot if we found the
exact set. Um or who knows? Maybe he's faking an illness in order
to record in a real hospital. I I still think it would be louder.
I still think it would be louder. Why didn't this guy just look
up the name of the hospital that I was at? I don't None of this
makes any sense. There's like so much
That's a great question.
It's almost like he would've done that or something. Maybe even
before watching the video.
And done a bit here.
I'm not even joking. I wouldn't be shocked if Perry looked up
the hospital and was like, "Oh, it's clearly the hospital." And
just done the video anyway. many insinuations.
I did. I Googled the name of Medical City Health Care. I did
Google that. I didn't see anything though. I didn't see anything.
If you Google Medical City Health Care, the hospital I was at
>> is actually the first result THAT COMES I didn't Dude.
He He actually doesn't get it.
Dude, Perry's debunked again. Perry's Perry's totally discredited
by this video, okay? It wasn't like his own video discredited
him as discredited him as a serious actor. This video is the
one that'll do it, okay? This is the video. He did that. He did
that cuz he just debunked Perry again.
He just totally debunked Perry again. >> see anything.
And now it's not loading. God damn it. He's like, "Yeah, guys.
Even if I am faking, I'm still dying. So, you need to give me
the money. You should give me the money cuz I have a freaking
hot wife, hot stay-at-home wife who refuses to do any work or
pick up pick up any of the slack. And I have a kid that I don't
know the name of, you know? It's um Brandon Buckingham and all
his friends, but most of Brandon Buckingham believe that if you're
poor, you should just die. That's what they think. I don't think
that. Yeah, for the record, I I don't think if you're poor, you
should die. And I think that
having health care regardless of your financial bracket is good.
I don't know what the He's just He's just making stuff up. So,
this guy is like a druggy.
And we have to foot the bill, really? I don't want to see it
on YouTube so you don't have to admit that you're like a drug
addict freak. The problem is this guy enjoys doing drugs more
than he enjoys taking care of his kid. And now he's making that
your problem by making you donate. So, if if what he was saying
is true and I am just like a hopeless drug addict that is like
destroying my health and doing so many drugs that I'm about to
be dead,
does that then make it okay to like mock me and make fun of me?
Kind of.
Given like uh apparently I heard the update he did was that he
was trying to do like cold plunges and holistic medicine before
going to the hospital.
Yeah, if I put those two things together that you did this to
yourself through drugs and that you're trying to use like holistic
medicine instead of going directly to the hospital, yeah, kind
of. Oh, and you don't have health insurance? Yeah, kind of. I
kind of think it's worth laughing at you. I kind of think you're
like a perfect example to hold up of new age
Yeah, I I think it's actually then it would actually become morally
okay to to to laugh at you. In my opinion. >> that situation.
And then he's saying, "I don't care
This has always been a great point, but yes, it becomes more
and more correct the more we go on. You have a kid. You have
a wife. You don't have health insurance. Do you have life insurance?
What happens to your stay-at-home mom, your stay-at-home sit
Not sister, either. Wife. And your kid, if you die and you don't
have life
What What do you do? What What What are they going to do? Like,
that's
horrifying, man. >> about poor people or the downtrodden
That's good. >> That's really good. That's nice. Isn't
drug addiction abuse the same thing? Yes, but the thing is the
thing I'm trying to point out to Anon, okay? The thing I'm trying
Okay. Okay. Okay. I can totally By the way, I'm going to be gay
here for a second. I totally agree there people on the internet
who operate in a way that's like totally crazy.
That like polite society doesn't function this way and it's like
a niche thing. Your friends operate in that same niche market.
Your a bunch of your friends operate in that same niche market.
People you're friends with now.
Like, none of us think that this is okay to just treat people
this way like in real life. And the hope would be that if you're
sitting in the hospital, you're not going to look at Perry's
video. Like, that to me is like you just look away. Yeah, it
sucks that somebody does that. You can just look away.
I think.
Or I maybe you report it or something. If If these were real
criticisms, they were tangible criticisms that people were worried
about.
I do Oh. Wait. Oh, do I say this? This is going to make me sound
insane. Does this not increase the likelihood that you believe
the the nitrous oxide
So, with the Turkey Tom allegations,
Turkey Tom's girlfriend
leaned into the nitrous oxide stuff.
Leaned into that. Put a lot of weight on
Now, Brandon's found the least credible person he can find to
attack for saying he faked his illness or was dishonest about
his illness.
So So, Perry becomes the face of like, "Oh, I want to accuse
Brandon Buckingham of something around the illness?
And now he's attacking
the at least credible guy. He's Yeah, he's he's building this
guy up as like, oh, this is totally crazy.
Bro, am I I I don't think that's insane.
That is like schizo thoughts. I don't have proof of this or anything.
Right? When Perry mentioned why you sick, he just was silent.
He's not said, no, that didn't happen.
And he even says, oh, so what if I did drugs and I got sick,
then you could just go after me?
I I don't get it. What don't you get, Billy Joe Buchet? Basically,
the allegation is uh Brandon Buckingham did crazy drugs. He was
like doing a lot of drugs and that he got sick and had this multi-system
organ failure because of his drug use. And that he then did this
like sappy thing where he's like, I can't take care of my kids
or my family. And it's And I I I can't have this. He didn't have
health insurance. He just planned his life horribly, okay? And
then he basically went to the internet begging. It's not that
you can't go to the internet begging, but you should go with
an accurate story. You shouldn't You shouldn't mislead people,
right?
Uh this is this is kind of weird now. I think it increases the
chance that Brandon did something like this. Uh that the drug
thing could be real. I I don't really think you can't run a GoFundMe
if you have if you've done drugs. I think it's a little dishonest
to just be like to lean into this and and not be Yeah, I I feel
like it's dishonest, but I also understand if you're in a situation
where you're going to die and leave your family financially destitute
do it. So, it's not like I total judgment. I would say
I don't know how much of a platform you should have after that
if you were going to do something like that.
Cuz you leave it up to people. I just I get really suspicious
cuz nothing about making this video makes any sense to me except
that you need somebody super discredited as the face of like
asking questions about your hospitalization.
You know what I'm saying?
The point he is that loser right-wing freaks like Brandon Buckingham
and his besties don't like calling people immigrants. They call
them illegal aliens, right? That's what they say. I am saying
that I do not want to use empathetic language for Brandon Buckingham
because he refuses to show any empathy whatsoever or anything
along those lines and I do to any of his associates or anybody
in a similar situation. I've actually never commented on immigration
or illegal aliens and this is all just a complete fabrication
by this guy who's trying to paint me in a negative light
to fulfill his little sick and twisted fantasy. So, yeah, that's
cool. Right? Like I could sit here and be like, oh, it's sad
to be addicted to drugs. I could say that. Does Brandon feel
the same way? No.
Okay, is Was that a denial? >> aliens and this is all just
a complete fabrication by this guy who's trying to paint me in
a negative light
to fulfill his little sick and twisted fantasy. So, yeah, that's
cool. Right? Like I could sit here and be like, oh, it's sad
to be addicted to drugs. I could say that. Does Brandon feel
the same way? No. He thinks that if you're addicted to drugs,
um make sure to show up when Brandon is filming so he can make
money off of you. That's what he thinks. Again, I have no idea
what he's talking about and just as an anecdote here, one of
the people that was featured in one of my drug documentaries
about Kensington, Philadelphia actually
So, that's like exactly what he means, obviously. I've no idea
what he's talking about here. No, you do. You're literally referencing
it. I have no idea what he's talking about here, but just in
case, here's the exact thing he's talking about here.
sober after the experience and then I later reconnected with
him, did a GoFundMe for him, raised over $6,000 and gave him
$7,500
to help his continued sobriety journey. So, it's just makes no
sense. I also spent my Thanksgiving in
giving out over $8,000 to homeless people on the streets of Kensington.
Um so, yeah, I don't I I I just how how can I respond to these
things when they're just made up just It's just completely
I think you you don't respond.
The only reason he got traction with the first tweet is because
Wendigoon
And the only reason he's going to get traction now with this
story at all is cuz you responded. Don't respond. You just don't
respond. >> This whole video just sucks and is stupid.
Wait, what's this? In loving memory of my big brother, Kyle Delaney.
Wait, so his brother also did a Did his brother also do a GoFundMe
scam? That's >> Bro, he's talking about my dead brother
>> Yeah, this this guy is like way out of bounds. Way way
out of bounds. I don't know. What do you guys at home think
Hold on. He is way out of bounds.
Can we do a GoFundMe
for Brandon Buckingham's plane ticket to Can we get Can we start
that? Anybody Anybody up for that? We're going to do a GoFundMe
to buy Brandon Buckingham's ticket to Valletta. I think we should
do this. I think we @BrandonBuckingham
I've started a GoFundMe. I will pay for your flight and accommodation
in Valletta as long as you film it. Thank you. for this. Immediately
$10,000 from Aiden, okay?
He's essentially saying my wife is a [__] I'm a drug
addict, I'm a scammer, I'm faking everything.
Um my brother's a scammer, my dead brother that is. I don't I
I don't even know. This guy is totally Christian, guys, totally
totally. And he's he's mocking my religion as well. He's mocking
Christianity. He's also mocking uh Your music? make rap music?
Dude, uh you know what I The one good person act of the day,
the one good person deed I will do today as I'm not going to
at this precise moment in time go find the song he made about
his brother and laugh at that on stream,
I'll leave that outside. I'll leave that out of the video. I
will move forward without having to go do that, okay? That is
the one concession you get from me in the good person front today,
okay? Has this guy made any rap music? Is he angry because he's
tried to rap and he just like sucks at it? Let's figure that
out here. My organs don't work. My organs don't work. My organs
don't work. My organs don't work. I went to Middle East, results
of Turkey these. I talked to Sam. He realized [__]
All right, this guy so Yeah, I will play the full version of
that though. Give me 1 second. Give me 1 second. My organs don't
work. My organs don't work. My organs don't work. My organs don't
work. I went to Middle East, results of Turkey these. I talked
to Sam. He realized [__] Okay, I spoke to Sam. He
said he was a damn good lover to the youngest of lords. She was
15. She should have known better. It's too fast of a song. It's
too fast of a song, guys. It's too fast of a song. You can't
freestyle this
And uh Ivy isn't plugged in and I'm looking at my nice kid and
he seems so disabled
and my wife's on the table getting pounded by Wendigoon while
I'm [singing] allowed to hear his tune talking about my breath
while he kicks my wife and goes
strip club for Moses saying for Moses I'm looking at my organs
and they are falling and I break sweat cuz I'm heating and all
because I said I [__]
>> It's literally a song mocking him dying of organ failure.
Why would you ever play that? He's like larping as Brandon singing
about how Brandon is a has organ failure, all of this stuff and
he's like led us directly to it. I
It's catastrophic, man. I don't know. I don't know what the [__]
this guy was
Well, actually do. I technically have a thesis now. Nicandros,
did you hear the thesis for why he's doing this? I think this
is just the most obvious reason. Nicandros, you heard the reason,
right?
I truly believe that this gives total validity to the nitrous
oxide stuff.
I think that he did have some weird [__] He's kind
of responsible for his own organ failure. And that he needs a
totally discredited person to be the face of like accusing him
of [__] like that. I think that's the only thing
that could possibly make any sense in my mind.
Other than that, I don't get it. I don't know. I don't understand.
There's no other possible explanation to me other than him just
being mad, but then I hope he flies to a Valletta and beats the
[__] out of Perry. >> results of Turkey these.
I talked to Sam. He realized [__] All right, this
guy so this guy is confirmed. >> Totally not not a totally
real Christian, not not a [__] loser suburban white
boy that wants to be a rapper whatsoever. >> Does this
guy hate white people? He's saying I'm a suburban white boy.
What's someone from Malta? What What are they? Are they Are they
not white? What the The Mediterranean mutt.
Mixed up Mediterranean mutt. There's no differentiating these
people anymore. >> hell is he? Is he What the like What
the hell is he?
I mean, probably like 5 or 10% Mediterranean mutt, but What the
[__] What the
the Huh?
>> What's the point You're a suburban white boy. What's
the point there? Wait, he's saying he's in the ICU right now.
Wait, cuz Wait, he's saying he's in the ICU. He's saying he's
in the ICU. Is this
No Jews in Malta? I don't know if that's true. Maybe a little
bit. But I would say he's probably got something in there, right?
Just cuz he's All the people around the Mediterranean are like
pretty intermixed in a lot of ways. Like you You got He's got
5 or 10% okay.
You don't have to pretend that it's like you think it's weird
to ask or wonder about that. I don't ask anybody that. I can
tell. Wait, cuz Wait, he's saying he's in the ICU. He's saying
he's in the ICU. Is this Is this what the ICU is usually like,
guys? Guys, Is this what the ICU usually looks like where it's
like there's a bunch of space, there's no noise or anything?
Stay-at-home wife wife It is not an ICU bed. Four days ago I
woke Is this what they do in the ICU? They put you with the puppy
pee mats and they they have the unplugged they have the unplugged
heart monitor and everything. Is that what they do? He's saying
he's this is the ICU. He's saying this is the ICU. I'm forced
to stay in the ICU as the doctors try different medications get
my heart pumping so I'm normally again. Dude. Dude. Insane. Insane.
This is not the ICU. So this guy is a ICU expert he's saying
it's not an ICU bed. Dude, I don't know enough about the ICU
to tell
Hold on. Hold on. He's an ICU expert and expert musician?
No shot. My organs don't work. My organs don't work. My organs
don't work. I went to the least two years old to two kitties.
I talked to Sam. He
I'm going to propose an alternative hypothesis.
Maybe he's not either of those things. Maybe he's not an ICU
expert or a professional musician. Possibly. Possibly. Possibly?
Possibly. You what bed is usually in there but this is definitely
in the ICU. I have medical paperwork showing that I'm in the
ICU.
What a snake?
Yo. Get it get a shot of that.
Woah. Is that like another animal man? That's way better than
this guy the Maltese manlet.
Could you like
get a shot of that animal over there cuz animals are cool. Nature
rocks, rivers,
trees. Is that a real snake? This guy has a big snake. Did you
just catch that snake? Yep. Is it a is that a rattlesnake? Is
it? No, it's just a rat snake. Oh man, I want nothing to do with
that. Holy sh
Yo. Look at that. That is horrifying. I don't want to be near
that. All right. Let me snake it by you. Holy crap.
Oh my god. >> for you right there. Yeah. There you go.
You want to say anything to the people?
How do you do? You just caught that thing? Yes, sir. Ain't nothing.
Just humans being dudes, man. That's what my videos are like.
I just meet people and I talk to them down by the river.
Some flat river rocks.
Nature. Animals.
Animals in nature. I'm going to take it home and keep it as a
pet. Really? Yes, sir. Hey, yo. [laughter]
>> That was awesome. Thank you, sir. Yes, sir. Thank you.
This video is crap. That was cool though. That was awesome. >> That
was really cool. Highlight of the video right there. So thanks
for staying tuned, you guys.
Is Jay talking to unban Perry from the Discord? Yeah, I unbanned
him like a couple hours ago.
I said I'd like to talk to him about it. Um I unbanned him he
messaged me. He literally messaged me and asked if he could be
unbanned from the Discord. And I was like, yeah, for sure. I
Yeah, I was like, oh, I would have yeah, I would have wanted
to talk to him. I ended up doing the politics thing. But um he
said if he's awake when I if I'm still streaming when he wakes
up then he'll come on stream. Um I'm going to be releasing on
Patreon a Patreon podcast with my brother where we're just going
to sit down and have casual conversation. Wait. I thought his
brother was dead. Isn't that the point of the song?
But the song's fake, too. Is the kind of commentary Perry would
do upon seeing this, okay? It's just an example of the kind of
commentary Perry would do meant to inflame and and enrage but
not actually true. There's like a different brother that's dead.
This brother isn't dead, obviously. But I just wanted you to
get an example of like the kind of thing Perry would say. All
right? So if you guys want to check that out that'll be on my
Patreon here pretty soon. The Bucky Can podcast. We're going
to be talking about what it's like for me to recover and and
all that kind of good stuff. And we'll be doing those every
He did exactly that and Brandon's fans in chat lost their mind.
I didn't see it. I didn't see it. I could just tell you exactly
what Perry would do cuz it's obvious right there, right? I'm
not joking. I didn't watch
I didn't watch it. I kind of want to maybe go watch some of those
collins
So we'll see. every week whether we're playing video games or
just chatting about stuff like the Jeffrey Epstein files. We
have good stuff coming on the way. So I really appreciate you
guys watching. We are going to continue walking at the park on
this beautiful day and we will see you next week. Thank you guys
so much. I'm really happy to be alive, happy to be making videos
and I am happy we saw that cool snake and that egret. So that's
it. Peace. I am overweight. That is true. That is true. Anyway,
I thank you.
I can't explain. If you'd seen, okay? >> Totally. Real
Christian.
If you'd seen Perry stream with Aiden
and the way he walks with his gut out just like shaking around,
you'd know there's absolutely no way Perry gives a [__]
about being fat. He straight up doesn't give a This guy could
be any size he would not care. There's no self-consciousness
there. He is like a complete lack of self-consciousness in that
front.
He's got like this big gut bouncing around and he's literally
like he's literally like leaning back and like sticking it out
and it's like bouncing as he walks around. He like struts around
the room. It's so funny, man.
Does not care. You just called him fat? That's funny. He doesn't
give a [__]
He is he is like the guy. Hold on. Uh Yeah, this guy right here.
This is like Brandon Buckingham's nightmare like sleep paralysis
demon.
It's like Perry, okay? It's like Perry and Perry this is what
Brandon Buckingham sees in his nightmares is Perry dancing around
like this around his room, okay? He like wakes up in a cold sweat
in the middle of the night and he just sees jester maxed Maltese
meatball dancing around at the foot of his bed, okay?
Crazy. I shouldn't have that up anymore. I feel bad. Oh Jesus
Christ. Okay. Do I want to go to the Perry stream now? I think
I want to go to the Perry stream now. Give me a second.
Give me a second. Give me a second. The Perry stream with the
collins.
Is it collins?
Purple Perry gaming.
Brandon What's up? It's me Purple Perry gaming. responds to me.
It's bad. Brandon Buckingham responds to me. I wasn't expecting
to do a stream right
I mean before we begin I I think it's time for a toast. Um um
to good health. Cheers.
Do you think that Brandon heard this in the hospital? Do you
think Brandon heard this in the hospital? A good job, Kevin.
You're only off by $300,000 but you missed 25, 26, 27. But it's
nitris.
No. No. He's sipping at the the nitris and like a big pile at
like a party. No. No. No. That's not the stream?
Well, I know hold on. I know it's not the stream but it's his
edited video of the reaction to the stream. Or sorry, the other
reaction to the video. I'm guessing does he have any of the collins
on it or is it just his reaction to the video? It's just his
reaction to the video. It looks like. Okay. an insane asylum
and then try to debate an insane person, you would wind up sounding
crazy. Did you get a shot of that bird over there? That's like
the one This guy sucks. This guy is just really unfunny. It's
very it's very difficult. It's very difficult to be this unfunny.
It's actually almost impressive. Is this like a slow burn so
bad it's good intentionally being unfunny humor? You know, liminal
liminal dog video no jump scares that what Brandon's making.
One good part of the video. Can you get a good zoom on that bird?
I think it's an egret. or like, oh, I'm going to opinions. Give
us your political opinions. Who did you vote for in 2024?
All right. This guy so this guy is [__] confirmed.
If this guy plays the rap so I'm going I'm I'm going to I'm dude,
please, man. Please. tried to rap and he just like sucks at it.
Let's figure that out here.
>> All right. This guy so >> this guy is confirmed.
Totally not not a good Dude, does anyone have the full tape?
Does anyone have the full I think that was also Jixaw. Jixaw,
did you work with Brandon on this video? Jixaw, did you work
with Brandon on this video?
You do have venom in your name. So is that really a fake snake?
That's kind of crazy. I just wanted to see Awesome. Thank you,
sir. Okay. I just wanted to see This video is crap. That was
cool though. That was awesome. That was really cool. Highlight
of the video right there. So thanks for staying tuned, you guys.
Um I'm going to be releasing on Patreon a Patreon podcast with
my brother where we're just going I thought your brother died
of heroin. So that was like all made up and you're just admitting
that? sit down and have casual conversation.
Big big boobs cabana. Exactly stopped for attention, you a man.
It's so obvious. Just saying whatever for engagement. Get a grip,
man, and enjoy this fiver. Well, I mean if it is sad then it's
I guess it's it is very kind of Brandon to make this video on
me. I do I do So I looks like he made what?
Over $400?
Got to be over 400, right?
I understand those are euros but I think he made
This probably more money than he's made in months.
This is like a crazy amount of money that Perry's making for
this stream.